[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Donald Trump apparently tried
to cover up the actual purpose of a June
2016 meeting between his son his
son-in-law his campaign manager and
Russian operatives promising official
Russian government dirt on Trump's
opponent intended to help Trump win the
presidency and his own son has now
confirmed this after a series of stories
that largely went under the radar that
appears to be what Special Counsel
Robert Muller is trying to prove right
now
a White House cover-up dictated by Trump
to hide the real and possibly criminal
purpose of that June 2016 meeting when
Donald Trump jr. submitted his statement
about the meeting to staffers of the
Senate Judiciary Committee last week he
all but convicted his father of what
could easily become an article of
impeachment charging cover-up and
obstruction of justice
Trump's seniors own responsibility
initially revealed matter-of-factly by
his own press secretary was underscored
again in Trump jr. statement within a
day of that statement came the further
report that Muller has told the White
House he wants to interview at least six
staffers and at least two of those were
perhaps involved in the events that led
to Trump's White House apparent cover-up
of the Russia meeting these stories
flashed by in moments that went almost
unnoticed like virtually everything else
in the kaleidoscopic nightmarish blur of
this three-card Monte game of a
presidency but it's really simple stuff
Trump juniors prepared statement
included this quote Robb Goldston
suggested that someone had official
documents and information that would
incriminate Hillary Clinton and her
dealings with Russia and that the
information would be very useful to the
campaign quoting again someone had
official documents and information in
fact in his June third email this
Goldston character had described the
documents as much more than just
official he wrote to Trump jr. that the
documents had been offered by quote the
crown prosecutor of Russia and quote
this is obviously very high-level and
sensitive information
as part of Russia and it's government's
support for mr. Trump
thus Donald Trump jr. had been told he
was being offered documents provided by
the Russian government to damage Hillary
Clinton and to get his own father
elected back to Trump jr. statement to
the Senate staffers I thought I should
listen to what Rob and his colleagues
had to say to the extent they had
information concerning the fitness
character or qualifications of a
presidential candidate I believe that I
should at least hear them out that would
be a textbook admission by Trump jr. to
an attempt to conspire with emissaries
of a foreign government Trump jr. may
not have known the an espionage laws of
this country nor the ones precluding
foreign contributions cash or otherwise
to an American campaign but he knew what
he was being offered and his statement
to the Senate staffers means his first
public explanation after the revelation
of the meeting was at best a lie by
omission it was a short introductory
meeting he said back then I asked Jared
Kushner and Paul Manafort to stop by we
primarily discussed a program about the
adoption of Russian children but it was
not a campaign issue at the time and
there was no follow-up of course the
real problem with that false July 8th
statement was clear the White House
press secretary miss Sanders confirmed
on the record that it was quote weighed
in on by Trump meanwhile it was reported
that in fact the President composed the
entire initial false statement flying
home from Germany on July 8th aboard Air
Force One Trump personally dictated a
statement in which Trump jr. said that
he and the Russian lawyer had primarily
discussed a program about the adoption
of Russian children when they met in
June 2016 according to multiple people
with knowledge of the deliberations
whether dictated or just weighed in on
the moment the president influenced the
statement on what Trump juniors meeting
was about he figured we brought that
statement into the White House he
brought that lie into the White House he
brought that cover-up into the White
House he brought that meeting into the
White House whether he weighed in on the
statement or dictated it word for word
Trump himself
formed it into an impeachable offense
and he transformed all the events
connected to it into potential White
House crimes and in his statement to
Senate staffers Trump jr. confirmed his
father's guilt by confirming that the
first statement the one his father
weighed in on or wrote was false and
that is why Muller has reportedly asked
to interview in addition to Reince
Priebus John Spicer White House Counsel
Don McGann and deputy counsel James
Burnham acting communications director
hope Hicks and possibly another White
House press aide named Josh rattle and
Hicks and raffle are the headliners here
why they quote were involved in internal
discussions in July over how to respond
to questions about the June 2016 meeting
the two communication staffers advocated
being transparent about the purpose of
the meeting of course as we know from
the first false statement that Trump jr.
issued in July the one his father either
dictated or weighed in on they were
apparently overruled
what Muller is apparently trying to do
with Hicks and raffle is similar to what
he's apparently doing with the White
House Counsel magan show how a crime
occurred in real time as reported there
is step-by-step evidence that McGann by
the way McGann and Priebus reportedly
just hired one of the top white-collar
crime lawyers in Washington Magan
stopped Trump from sending the first
draft of trumps letter firing James
Comey because of Russia in this part of
the case Muller is trying to show how
another crime occurred in real time by
proving Hicks and raffle told Trump be
transparent about your son's meeting and
maybe even warned him Jr's meeting might
have been a crime and Trump went ahead
and did the wrong thing anyway
in both cases Muller is going for the
legal equivalent of closed-circuit
security video showing Trump being told
not to break the law
showing Trump ignoring that advice
showing Trump then breaking the law
anyway if Muller can do this just once
let alone in both events Trump is
finished and remember also for months
everything that Trump jr. and the Trump
gang have said about that Russian
meeting has quickly proved to be a lie
in March 2017 Trump
Jr told the New York Times that while he
may have had meetings with people from
Russia quote certainly none that I was
representing the campaign in any way
shape or form on July 9th 2017 Trump jr.
issued a second statement which
indicated that his July 8th 2017
statement was not the truth on July 11th
2017 Trump jr. released the email chain
about the six-person meeting and when
Sean Hannity asked him so far as you
know as far as this incident is
concerned this is all of it Trump jr.
answered this is everything this is
everything and three days later it
wasn't a Russian lobbyist with ties to
Putin revealed he was also at the
meeting even though Trump jr. never
mentioned that nor the fact that there
weren't six people there there were
eight on July 12th Trump's lawyer Jay
Sekulow told Chris Cuomo that the
president was not involved in drafting
Trump juniors first statement on July
16th Sekulow repeated this to Chuck Todd
quote the president was not involved in
the drafting of that statement but on
July 31st Sarah Huckabee Sanders Trump's
press secretary said of the statement
quote the president weighed in as any
father would he certainly didn't dictate
but like I said he weighed in offered
suggestion like any father would do
Trump jr. lied at least once about
whether or not there was a meeting
he lied at least once about what the
meeting was about he lied at least once
about how many people were at the
meeting he lied about having revealed
everything about the meeting Sekulow
possibly lied twice about Trump at least
contributing to the writing of the
statement if the Washington Post
reporting about Trump writing the
statement is correct Huckabee Sanders
apparently lied about Trump not
dictating it and Trump himself each time
he dismissed the meeting as unimportant
he lied each time he declared the
russian's scandal a witch-hunt fake news
an excuse made up by Democrats he has
lied and lied and lied and lied and lied
happily his own son has now caught him
in one of those lies and in so doing
brought the cover-up of some of the lies
directly into the White House and into
the purview of the special counsel
Muller and it is Muller who will bring
these lies to the house
the judiciary when it inevitably takes
up its constitutional responsibility and
impeaches this serial and criminal liar
resist remove piece my book based on
more than 100 of these commentaries will
be released on October 17th and you can
pre-order it now if you wish thank you
in advance